Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
En los 1600
la Compañía Holandesa de las Indias
Orientales empleó cientos de barcos
para comerciar con oro, porcelana,
especias y sedas en todo el mundo.
Pero ejecutar esta operación masiva
no era barato.
Con el fin de financiar
sus costosos viajes,
la empresa se dirigió
a los ciudadanos privados,
individuos que podrían invertir dinero
para apoyar el viaje.
a cambio de una parte
de las ganancias del buque.
Esta práctica permitió a la compañía
realizar viajes aún más importantes,
aumentando los beneficios
para ellos y sus inversores inteligentes.
Vendiendo estas acciones en cafeterías y
puertos de embarque en todo el continente,
la Compañía Holandesa de las
Indias Orientales inventó, sin saberlo,
el primer mercado de valores del mundo.
Desde entonces, las empresas han
recogido fondos de inversores dispuestos
a apoyar todo tipo de empresas.
Y hoy, el mercado de valores
tiene escuelas, carreras e incluso
canales de televisión completos
dedicados a entenderlo.
Pero el mercado de valores moderno es
significativamente más complicado.
que su encarnación original.
¿Cómo las empresas y los inversores
utilizan el mercado hoy en día?
Imaginemos una nueva compañía de café
que decide lanzarse al mercado.
Primero, la compañía se anunciará
a los grandes inversores.
Si piensan que la empresa
es una buena idea,
toman la primera oportunidad de invertir,
y luego patrocinan la oferta pública
inicial de la compañía o IPO.
Esto lanza la empresa
en el mercado público oficial,
donde cualquier empresa o individuo que
crea que el negocio podría ser rentable
puede comprar una acción.
Comprar acciones hace dueños parciales
del negocio a los inversionistas.
Su inversión ayuda a la empresa a crecer,
y a medida que se vuelve más exitosa,
más compradores pueden ver el potencial
y comenzar a comprar acciones.
A medida que aumenta
la demanda de esas acciones,
también lo hace su precio, aumentando
el costo para los posibles compradores,
y elevando el valor de las acciones
de la empresa que las personas ya poseen.
Para la compañía,
este aumento del interés ayuda
a financiar nuevas iniciativas.
y también aumenta
su valor de mercado global
mostrando cuánta gente
está dispuesta a invertir en su idea.
Sin embargo, si por alguna razón una
empresa empieza a parecer menos rentable
lo contrario también puede suceder.
Si los inversores piensan que el valor
de sus acciones va a disminuir,
venderán sus acciones con
la esperanza de obtener ganancias
antes de que la empresa pierda más valor.
Conforme las acciones se venden
y su demanda disminuye,
el precio de las acciones cae,
y con ello, el valor
de mercado de la empresa.
Esto puede dejar a los inversores
con grandes pérdidas,
a menos que la empresa comience
a lucir rentable nuevamente.
Este balancín de la oferta y la demanda
está influenciada por muchos factores.
Las empresas están bajo la ineludible
influencia de las fuerzas del mercado.
como el precio fluctuante
de los materiales,
cambios en la tecnología de producción.
y los costos cambiantes del trabajo.
Los inversores pueden estar preocupados
por los cambios en el liderazgo,
mala publicidad o factores mayores
como nuevas leyes y políticas comerciales.
Y por supuesto,
muchos inversores simplemente
están listos para vender acciones valiosas
y perseguir intereses personales.
Todas estas variables causan
el ruido cotidiano en el mercado,
lo que puede hacer que las empresas
parezcan más o menos exitosas.
Y en el mercado de valores,
parecer perder valor a menudo
lleva a perder inversionistas,
y a su vez, perder valor real.
La confianza humana en el mercado
tiene el poder de desencadenar todo,
desde auges económicos
hasta crisis financieras.
Y esta variable difícil de rastrear
es por lo que la mayoría
de los profesionales
promueven inversiones
confiables a largo plazo.
por tratar de hacer dinero rápidamente.
Sin embargo, los expertos crean
constantemente herramientas
esforzándose para aumentar
sus posibilidades de éxito
en este sistema altamente impredecible.
Pero el mercado de valores no es solo
para los ricos y poderosos.
Con internet,
los inversionistas corrientes
pueden comprar acciones
en muchas de las mismas formas
en que un gran inversor lo haría.
Y a medida que más gente se educa
sobre este complejo sistema.
también pueden comerciar acciones,
apoyar a las empresas en las que cree,
y perseguir sus objetivos financieros.
El primer paso es conseguir inversión.